las 48 horas de interrogatorio la
justicia francesa abrió una
investigación por homicidio voluntario
al policía que mató a un joven de 17
años en un retén el fiscal deaj el
suburbio de París donde ocurrieron los
hechos pidió que el agente permanezca
bajo arrestolita
en base a la información recabada hasta
el momento la fiscalía considera que el
uso del arma de fuego no fue legalmente
justificable en sus declaraciones el
policía justificó sus acciones como un
intento de impedir que el vehículo
escapara de nuevo por la conducción
temeraria del piloto lo que le hizo
temer que el auto golpeara a alguien o a
él mismo al arrancar
a la fiscalía no le convence esta
explicación y la clave de la
investigación recae en las palabras que
intercambiaron los agentes antes del
disparo que se oyen en el video de los
hechos
hay otra investigación abierta por falso
testimonio del policía que en su primera
declaración aseguró que disparó porque
el conductor lo intentó atropellar una
versión que se contradice con el vídeo y
con los testigos de los hechos y una
muerte que aumenta la indignación de la
población con la actuación policial en
Francia
este policía es una vergüenza una
vergüenza para la policía en general y
es momento de que las autoridades actúen
para depurar la fuerza pública
pero el ministro de Justicia defiende al
cuerpo policial
este caso es contra un agente de policía
no contra la policía en general ponerlos
todos en el mismo saco es intolerable
el año pasado la policía mató a 13
personas por supuestamente negarse a
detenerse en retenes de tráfico en 2017
un cambio en la legislación amplió los
casos en que la policía puede usar sus
armas de fuego un texto ahora
cuestionado